hello and welcome everyone to this
session my name is nick lewins and i
lead financial services at microsoft
research
today's topic is data sharing ecosystems
powered by privacy enhancing
technologies in just a moment we'll have
a panel of industry experts in
conversation on this topic but first
we're going to kick off with some
visionary words from bill borden who is
microsoft's corporate vice president for
financial services
over to you bill
thanks nick
great to be here to talk to you about a
vision for financial services
so post pandemic financial services
institutions are moving full speed ahead
to take advantage of a host of long-term
benefits presented by digital
transformation to be agile build
resilience innovate and grow
this has created an unprecedented demand
for all kinds and forms of data and
cloud technologies
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service software as a service
solutions with data analytics and
machine learning at the core
are all top of mind
data is on the move from thousands of
on-prem data centers to a small number
of hyperscale cloud providers bringing
huge opportunities to replace the
industry's data copying batch processes
for in-place sharing of live data in the
cloud
looking forward we see where the
industry is fundamentally transforming
along three dimensions
first
all interactions are delivered digitally
and every aspect is extensively
personalized based on a deep
understanding of customer needs and in
service of their financial well-being
that includes things like embedding
human sales and service interaction via
digital
so we see a renewed focus on
personalization of digital experiences
integrating human collaboration into
digital online sales and service
of course digital interactions create a
data set that can drive better and
better experiences in what we call a
digital feedback loop
second data in ai data and ai will be
applied in every decision process of the
organization
implementing digital feedback loops that
drive continuous optimization
optimization for customers employees
products in operations
norms for responsible use of ai will
have made a common place to use
sophisticated ai in more heavily
regulated use cases such as credit risk
assessment and financial advice
rapid advances in natural language
processing will make it possible to
parse and reason over complex concepts
found in regulation contracts and legal
interpretations
and thirdly
we see the embedding of financial
services inside the experiences of other
industries such as retail logistics and
supply chain
this means payments and similar
financial processes are embedded in the
digital experience that the customer is
actually trying to achieve
this is because the financial processes
are usually considered in the eyes of
the customer friction that is necessary
to achieve something else
so the endpoint of digital
transformation of financial services is
that this friction will be removed and
the financial service will be entirely
integrated in real time into the
customer experience or business process
that it is serving
so in summary we're seeing a future that
looks something like intelligent open
banking on steroids where humans
incorporated into the experience are on
demand
all of these trends speak strongly to
the central role that data will play in
the future of the industry
this includes customer data that you are
the custodian of data generated by your
business data sourced from your
ecosystem and open commercial and
alternative data sets
i'm really excited about what the
industry will build and what new
technologies will be invented to allow
data to be used for insight while
protecting data rights and privacy of
the data subjects and data owners
we are working closely with microsoft
research and its industry research team
to drive exploration of new technologies
that can provide breakthroughs in all of
the areas required to deliver this
vision of the industry
it's a very exciting time for tech and a
very exciting time for financial
services
as we heard from bill the digital
economy of the future is built on data
and interconnectivity last decade's
major trend was the ubiquitous adoption
of cloud connected devices and it could
be well be that the equivalent in the
next decade will be the ubiquitous
adoption of cloud connected data sets
these data products will be shared
within an ecosystem to create truly
frictionless experiences to create ai
and ml insights that power new products
new experiences
and protect against societal harm such
as money laundering and financial crime
in microsoft research
we're running a portfolio of initiatives
to bring forward this vision including
strong cryptographic protection of
sensitive data elements in cloud data
estates ai for quants and responsible ai
in the financial industry
and of course the topic of today's
session policy-based data sharing
powered by privacy enhancing
technologies
this research is driven by the
realization that data liquidity of the
type we're talking about will only ever
happen to the extent that it's possible
to protect privacy to use data within
its approved purposes to protect
commercial interests and licensing of
the data to comply with bank secrecy
laws and with customer expectations on
privacy
making these assurances is not easy when
the data is copied from one industry
participant to the next as is common in
the pre-cloud industry architecture
as the industry moves to cloud
there's the opportunity for in-place
sharing in the cloud
and cloud-native data management
practices to replace data copying
between market participants
we're seeing these themes come up in
multiple industry contexts and not just
in financial services and as a key part
of numerous policy initiatives globally
for example there's the open banking
movement and its extension into embedded
finance
the international data spaces and trusts
projects for european data sovereignty
the future of financial data
intelligence sharing in the uk and the
singapore banking association's trusted
data sharing framework
as this new data economy is formed one
of the key pieces will be technologies
that can provide the required strong
privacy guarantees
these are often called pets or privacy
enhancing technologies
they're a family of different technical
methods that provide strong guarantees
against information leakage
they're necessary to move beyond the
procedural and contractual controls for
example data use contracts attestations
and access control lists which are the
current best practice for controlling
data usage between organizations
luckily there are a number of such
technologies that are emerging and are a
focus of effort in the research
community broadly and in microsoft
research specifically
these include
trusted execution environments
which protect data by performing
computation inside an isolated part of
secure processes
microsoft has a number of leading
products in this space under the name of
azure confidential computing and as an
example we've worked with the royal bank
of canada to create a virtual clean room
solution for data sharing
then there's differential privacy in
which enough statistical noise is added
to query results in order to limit
aquaria's ability to infer specific data
values
we have a strong collaboration with
harvard and open source solutions in
this space
and there's homomorphic encryption which
is computation on data whilst it's still
encrypted
we have perhaps the most widely used
open source sdk in that space
and finally there are a number of
cryptographic schemes such as secure
multi-party computation and zero
knowledge proofs which allow joint
computation of results or proofs without
sharing the underlying data with a
number of implementation sdks available
for from microsoft research and others
in this space
so to dive deeper into the use cases and
the research status of pets
let me introduce our panelists for today
professor florian kirschbaum from the
university of waterloo computer science
department who is an acm distinguished
scientist and program co-chair for the
pets 2021 symposium
and dr cedric mombre pets researcher
from the emerging technologies group at
swiss multinational bank ubs who holds a
phd in mathematics from eth in
switzerland
so now on to our panel questions
this first question is for cedric
what use cases for pets are most
commonly discussed in the industry and
what would it mean for industries such
as financial services if these methods
can be deployed at scale
ionic thanks a lot for the introduction
so
there are currently many use cases using
various techniques that are being
discussed in the industry
and as you can imagine data is one of
the most important strategic assets in
financial services
so it not only supports the
competitiveness of existing business
areas but it also creates new
opportunities
as a part of insight-driven business
models and and value chains
so the challenge in financial services
is that this data often includes
sensitive and private information so
this means it has a high risk profile
and there are also
many data privacy restrictions that
apply
and so protecting this data and at the
same time extracting value from it is a
key objective in financial services
so when it comes to concrete use cases
in the industry i think we've seen
several ideas being
uh that have been floating around for
quite a while now and
these ideas employ techniques such as
zero knowledge proofs and differential
privacy and secure multi-computation
as well as many others
and when it comes to the potential use
cases i guess
these use cases aren't only limited to
the financial services industry but are
also applicable in other places as well
so i guess one common use case relates
to the analysis of data that's
distributed across data jurisdictions
so these data jurisdictions they can be
well real jurisdictions or kind of
internal ones defined by
regulations so to speak
and in certain cases the data cannot
move across these boundaries imposed by
these jurisdictions
and so the idea here is that using
privacy enhancing technologies you can
actually still do an analysis on this
data
uh combine it in a
private way across these jurisdictions
and gain insight from it
so let me think quickly
sorry about that
um
so one idea is to use private set
intersection
um
and apply that to
different business areas that have
possibly a common set of clients and so
you can use private settings section to
figure out which clients are common to
two different business areas
and
based on this intersection you can do
something like a joint sales campaign
and so another idea of using private
sector dissection is to compute
something like the overlap of
of customer bases of two companies that
are planning on doing a merger for
example
and so we see that many potential use
cases are based on the fact that
regulations impose these restrictions on
data movement and in certain cases you
don't really need the data itself but
just some kind of aggregate statistic
uh from the combined data set
so that's one
common use case in the industry i guess
there are also many other use cases that
rely on differential privacy and
synthetic data
and so these techniques they add noise
too and also
generate statistically similar data sets
and by doing this you can actually
process and analyze the data in a
different data jurisdiction so this
means that you could develop
quantitative models
with synthetic data from other
jurisdictions of course you have
questions regarding
things like the utility versus the
privacy of the data sets but in general
these are valid use cases that are
currently under investigation
and so zero knowledge proofs have also
been a big topic in the financial
services industry
so for example with zero knowledge
proofs you can demonstrate that a
certain number lies within a certain
range
and you can do this without exposing the
value and so this allows you to prove
that certain financial conditions are
satisfied which of course has
implications for many other things
so for example if you apply for a
mortgage um
you could prove that your salary is
within a certain range which would then
be a statement of proof of your credit
worthiness for a bank
and
these zero knowledge proofs they can
also be used in other cases within banks
for example
the the know your client process
that's a lengthy process within banks
and in this process the banks have to
verify that a potential client
um well
well they have to verify the identity of
a potential client and actually show
that this client has
um will or satisfy certain
attributes and using zero knowledge
proofs you can actually validate these
attributes and keep the client's data
private at the same time so
we have another really nice application
there zero knowledge proofs
so when it comes to secure multi-party
computation there are also several ideas
related to this that are
have been floating around um
i guess here
one thing to note is that with secure
multi-party computation
the data processing is split between
multiple parties but the inputs of the
parties is kept private and so this
allows for data collaboration
and
using secure multi-party computation you
could do interesting things like compute
aggregate risk exposures of multiple
financial institutions
in order to get a system-wide view on
the total risk exposure
or you could do other things with secure
multi-party computation for example um
secure trading
so that's also an interesting topic
uh secure multi-party computation it
allows that you it well it means that
you can actually match buy and sell
orders of financial instruments
without any party ever seeing any prices
or volumes
and so only the outcome of the
transaction has been revealed to the
parties
and i think that something similar has
actually already been been done in a
in a practical example so there's a
famous example of a secure auction in
denmark
and you can try to take that same idea
and extend it to other use cases
so as you can see there are many ideas
for
privacy enhancing technologies that are
floating around and
i only mentioned a few techniques but of
course there are other ideas related to
trusted execution environments and and
homomorphic encryption
and i guess it's up to the financial
firms to well figure out how to employ
these privacy enhancing technologies uh
to get the most benefit for their
clients
thank you uh florian would you like to
add anything on use cases cedric i think
you gave a very good overview thank you
very much for that i i want to add a
little bit of a systemization to it as
researchers like to do and i think that
we can see that privacy enhancing
technologies are applied
alongside
the entire data science life cycle
so we see that things are employed at
the face of data
acquisition data collection where most
of the cases that cedric now mentioned
were being deployed but they're also
privacy preserving and enhancing
technologies are used later down the
road when we actually train
models to predict um
or when we actually use
machine learning models or other kind of
data prediction models in order to do
that so we actually see
privacy enhancing technologies
um in in the entire data science life
cycle fantastic
so florian next question is for you what
are the hard research problems that need
to be tackled across these spaces of
pets and which are the most active and
exciting areas of research that you've
seen to solve those hard problems
well well thank you nick for this great
question
so fundamentally i think one of the big
problems that we see in privacy
enhancing technology is
is that we really do not really know
what privacy actually means
so we have been talking about
and cedric has been talking about a lot
about technical privacy so data
minimization
and that is certainly the
concept that we need for technical
privacy on the other hand we have legal
aspects where in a lot of cases the
question is where is data being
processed and actually
cedric talked about
circumventing
legal uh
regulations with privacy technology so
this is another interesting aspect of
whether or not these things could meet
and most importantly what we are
currently seeing is
there is a very important user aspect in
in privacy
so for a very long time privacy
researchers have talked about the only
way privacy enhancing technologies are
going to be adopted is by regulation
however what we are currently seeing is
that there actually is a lot of
pull by the users to implement privacy
enhancing technologies in systems and
companies are trying to actively shape
their privacy perception by employing
such technologies
and this is a fundamental shift
because we now no longer as
technologists have to implement certain
regulations
um or or try to circumvent
circumrelations
but
on the other hand actually
having to cater for a user's need and we
really don't know what that users need
mean
so so i can give a couple of examples so
we've been talking about differential
privacy right so differential privacy
protects an individual in a data set
however
what
that specifically means for example if
we apply
machine learning models whether or not
the entire data set has an impact
on
the the inference i want to make or only
the individual is something we really
don't always know and we cannot really
determine our priority so we really
don't know whether or not differential
privacy is a technology that can
protect us in in that way
and it is not a technology where we know
whether or not users
understand it or
users
can appreciate the consequences of
differential privacy
so so uh having a more holistic view
and adjusting the privacy technologies
to the needs and uh
expectations of the user
are really what we need to tackle in
privacy enhancing technologies in the
future
yeah it's certainly true that modern
concepts of privacy go beyond just
keeping information secret which has
kind of traditionally been the focus of
cryptographic researchers and so on and
extending the concepts such as whether
consent has been granted for the use of
a particular piece of data for a
particular purpose and so i'm very keen
to see
the the research community start to
focus on strong controls for that
element of privacy as opposed to just um
you know
cryptographic methods or methods that
promise strong degrees of
of data secrecy
um
and so to flip that question around the
other way florian which of these
technologies do you see as closest to
broad adoption in practice in your
opinion given as you said you need to
consider the specific use case when
you're contemplating which of these
techniques
in isolation or combination could solve
for that particular use case
so there are a couple of things to add
to this the first thing is we've always
as i said we've all been token and
there was this folklore knowledge that
privacy is not really something that is
being picked up however we're currently
seeing that most of these really
advanced cryptographic uh and other
techniques that cedric are has been
talking about are now being used more
and more and what i believe that we will
actually see being deployed
is a combination of techniques
so to give you an example
we already have and microsoft actually
is actively using differential privacy
local differential privacy in microsoft
windows in order to collect data so we
have a use case of data collection again
and we have a technology that we can use
uh however the in order to still get the
benefit of the data
the mathematical protection the
guarantee that differential privacy
provides needs to be actually
circumvented needs to be reduced to a
almost
unimportant
quantity however if we now combine
this with trusted execution environments
homomorphic encryption or multi-card
decomputation and other forms
uh of encrypted computation uh we can
really actually
leverage the benefit of uh differential
privacy and the other technologies so
what i believe is that uh in terms of
future deployments what we're going to
see is uh the different privacy
technologies including as you mentioned
consent or user perception playing off
of each other
and
having technologies that that
complement each other and give a greater
benefit than each individual technology
of itself uh and uh in such a way us
being able to get the the best out of
all of them
uh rather than uh taking an aspect in
order to to even
pin down further on that is
that we see
we have these encrypted computations and
we have consent and we have
um
output privacy by differential privacy
but actually only their combination is
really capable
and complements nicely to each other
in order to provide us protection
fantastic florian would you like to add
anything on the hard research problems
that you're seeing
and which of these methods are closest
to a broad adoption in practice
sorry that was for cedric
okay um
yeah i mean
i
basically agree with everything that
florian has said
um
but also from um
from an industry perspective um
[Music]
i guess one of the research problems
that we
don't have enough knowledge of is
pretty much related to the practical
implementations of these technologies
and um i'm not really talking about the
security of the underlying protocols but
more about the security of the practical
implementations of certain use cases so
i'm thinking about certain situations
where users can in some way game the
system so to speak
for example if you're a company and you
have a competitive knowledge and you
want to let users access it you might do
this in the form of an encrypted model
but then that raises the question of
model information leakage attacks right
so i'm talking about model extraction
and other possible security threats that
might arise from this uh well from this
deployment and so i guess that's a big
question
that arises when we try to deploy these
technologies and of course
every financial firm is always
interested in figuring out what can go
wrong
and that's pretty much where
the industry desires more information or
more research
thank you again cedric these were very
good comments i i want to relate them
back
to what i said initially if we're
thinking about
privacy in later stages of the
data science life cycle as you mentioned
inference and protection of models
generation of models we still have a
definitely several research challenges
but get but again as i said uh in the
other comment is if we combine different
privacy technologies
uh we might actually be able to tackle
these challenges as well now that i'm i
agree that all of these challenges are
solved uh but i can give you some
highlights for example on the ones
uh that you mentioned
so we can use technology like again
encrypted computation all three forms
that nick mentioned at the beginning
in order to protect the inference
and if we want to protect against
queries and leakage from the inference
we can
use other techniques that for allow
allows for example tracing of models
such as fingerprinting and
or watermarking or other types of
technologies
that enable these types of things so
overall we do have a a range of
technologies in the entire space
of data science in the life cycle that
we can hopefully employ in the future to
protect also these use cases
that you rightfully mention
it sounds very much from what you're
saying florian that um there's not one
silver bullet privacy enhancing
technology where you can just tick the
box and just so just apply this one
technology to my uh my algorithm and
it's gonna solve all of these privacy
protection
problems that it's much more a case of
you need to understand the use case and
you maybe need to design a solution that
comprises a number of these different
privacy enhancing technologies to
provide the specific privacy protections
that your use case requires is that the
way that you're thinking about it
i i fully agree nick
you also have to understand that people
are still researching what data science
is and the data science process changes
all the time and we're inventing new
data process technologies and very often
privacy is an afterthought
that needs to
adjust to these new developments enhance
them and make him private and secure and
so this is indeed uh something where we
need a lot of different types of
technologies as you said in order to
combine them
that's a really interesting point um
just by combining all these different
privacy enhancing technologies
kind of like building blocks
you shouldn't forget that you're also
increasing the complexity of the system
right and that's when human failure
might start to creep in and so you
the challenge doesn't become easier but
it does enable many new applications and
it should be worth it
yes perhaps it's a job of the future the
uh the privacy
privacy enhancing technology
engineer or architect or something that
we're going to need a lot of those
people in the industry
to
deploy these technologies as we move
forward well i'm interested um what has
attracted each of you to spend your
careers looking into this space
so florian would you like to go first
and just tell us give us some insight as
to why you've chosen this space as a
space to spend your career focusing on
uh
it it's certainly a very interesting
area and i enjoy um
the aspects of
these different things that play
together here
it was a little bit of an accident for
me as well but
as it is often is with a career but one
thing i particularly like is
to have an algorithmic challenge
and
in security or in privacy we very often
have
an additional complication to the
algorithmic challenge
which is
to prevent something unwanted from
happening
and to incorporate that into an
algorithm that otherwise achieves the
desired goal
is a very
very interesting kind of challenge that
always fascinated me
and cedric what what what attracted you
to work in this space
um
i kind of see these techniques as a way
to give control back to the user or
client right so
uh it's a way of counteracting potential
misuse of private data
and even though these techniques they're
still in well in an early stage when it
comes to deployment uh they enable
collaboration across
various players across various companies
and industries
and my hope is that this new form of
collaboration or this enablement of
collaboration will lead to new
applications that kind of make the
economy much more efficient and and then
everybody benefits
fantastic
another question for you both um
to start to close out the session if
people are interested in this space and
i'm thinking here both
people in the research community and
people
on the mall consumption side people from
financial services organizations and
other industries if they're interested
in finding out more about this space
what conferences resources
would you highlight for people to start
to get a better overview in this space
and become involved in the community
uh florian do you want to kick off there
sure happy to so so fundamentally i
believe this is a challenge generated by
computers
and it has to be a challenge solved by
or humans using those computers so so i
very much believe in in
the fact that
computer science will have to solve
uh the privacy challenge that computer
science generated
and uh as such there are a lot of
interesting kind of venues one which you
already mentioned the the pets uh
conference which is the leading
conference specialized on privacy
enhancing technologies it's a very open
community that welcomes practitioners
and
researchers
it is technically focused but also in
technology it's open from for a lot of
different type of aspects of
of computer science from human computer
interaction
uh
of course over cryptography but also
into machine learning and others so
there's a really
a confluence of
technology that is coming together and
you can get a very good overview of what
the current technical challenges are
and on the other hand there are a lot of
interesting organizations
that
have taken a lot of effort
into collecting information on the
subject
in germany there is of course always the
famous una penguin discharge land
starting centre lisbeth
which cedric for sure knows uh which has
collected a great source of information
and has actually made an effort also to
systemize it
to some extent and there are very many
other sources and many other privacy
commissioners
which have done a very good job at
providing
an overview of the challenges and
information that are out there
cedric would you like to add to that
yes um so
one thing to note is that the regulators
they've also kind of jumped up jumped on
the topic and for example the financial
conduct authority they've done
hackathons based on this on privacy
enhancing technologies there are other
organizations out there like the world
economic forum the eu they all have
working groups devoted to this topic so
you can find a wealth of information
there with those organizations and maybe
on a personal note what i like to do is
i like to use the archive so that's an
online repository for
scientific preprints and just by looking
at the latest publications there and and
reading the abstracts you can find out a
lot of information of what's going on in
the field and so i think that helps
immensely
yeah some of the resources that i point
people to uh the summary reports from
the world economic forum on pro use of
privacy enhancing technologies in
financial services which is very good
summary and the royal society report
from the uk
which also provides a great overview of
these technologies and their strengths
and opportunities
and also i saw that the uk information
commissioner's office recently came up
with a pets adoption guide which is a
nice play on words
and that that's a great resource as well
for for understanding these technologies
and
the ways that they can be deployed
well i'd like to start to close out here
by thanking you both for spending the
time with us today and for providing
such a fascinating insight into the
future of data sharing with these
privacy enhancing technologies it's been
a most enjoyable conversation i'm really
excited to see how this technology
changes the world in the years to come
thanks again to both of you